it's really good to see ariana grande
singing again after all the trauma that
she has been through lately even if her
performance on today's Ellen didn't go
quite as planned mentioning her
ex-fiance in thank you next while
dressed and Bridal white and surrounded
by wedding reception decor Ariana was
sending a message just twenty three days
after they called off their I Do's
Grande and her girls even gave us First
Wives Club vibes but then this happened
the 25 year old recovered only to have
another mishap did Ari leave Ellen
hanging this caught off-guard moment was
real according to multiple sources
Ariana wasn't expecting to speak for the
first time about the breakup and her ex
Mac Miller's accidental cocaine and
fentanyl overdose you've had a rough
here we all love you we support you
slightly recoiling and backing away from
Ellen's mic sources close to production
tell us ariana was caught by surprise
and was never supposed to chat with
Ellen after her second performance
[Music]
earlier grande had killed it during a
solo of her hit breathing getting
congrats from DeGeneres
does anybody have a better voice than
that that is likening but Ariana really
broke apart during thank you next
recalling her parents divorced when she
was able
[Music]